port
alors eddy mitchell est ce que comme
tous les mecs de 64 on fait du sport
pour fait croire que vous allez 54 ans
non j'en fais mais d'abord faux j'en
fais très peu
bon ok c'est bon mais ça m'a pas pris
après longtemps il avait simplement pas
beaucoup de temps donc non plus vous
aurez éviter ça si tous les mecs de 64
ans vous comprenez rien au rap et bien
sûr comprendre pourquoi le comprendrait
attention quand je ne comprends pas
c'est à un parler paru très très très
précis j'ai annoncé une langue j'ai pas
la prétention de comprendre et
musicalement c'est c'est vraiment là
c'est récompenses dont on comprend tout
il ya quand tu trouves un troisième
accord
c'est ce qu'on disait des yéyés alex
henry n'avait pas la qualité de textes
les yeah yeah qu'on les rameurs
aujourd'hui mais ils ont la qualité mais
je lui parle des rappeurs vous qui
commande qui sont passés de l'autre côté
ils sont devenus même ddd star et et
caetera et qui font de la chanson
moi je vous parle du vrai rap août où
les types parlant à l'enlever a été un
bon match et ne s'est pas parlé comme ça
je me comprends pas ce qu'on me raconte
depuis cependant acculé par dont janet
non mais c'est pas grave non meilleur et
c'est formidable j'ai rien contre du ça
ne me touche pas je veux pas vous le
présenter je vais pas faire le plus
durement même convoi que c'est super
lieu qu'est ce qui a comme talent dans
les banlieues ouais ouais ouais j'y
comprends rien
comme tous les mecs de 64 ans vous
surveillez votre cholestérol je suis
soigné depuis bien avant
oui mais c'est comme tous les mecs de 64
ans vous essayé de draguer des jeunes en
boîte bas déjà les boîtes c'est trop
tard pour moi on va faire des matinées
voyez là c'est l'ancienne comme tous les
mecs de 64 ans d'acheter une porsche
histoire de le croire que jen annoncé un
break mégane une austin où j'arrive à
rentrer dedans c'est comme tous les mecs
de 64 ans pour regretter l'époque des
vinyles oui hein
le son était meilleure non c'est parce
que l'histoire de son annonce et de la
beauté de la pochette c'est vrai tout
comme je regrette d'un truc le plus
proche qui était la zone vidéo discret
c'est le gramophone
est ce que comme tous les mecs de 64 ans
vous trouvez un peu crétin les chanteurs
d'aujourd'hui
non non non non non non on a lu tournant
on ad'autres 12 aussi le retour de la
chanson française façon années 50 la
avec show men à barberaz est ce que
comme tous les mecs de 64 ans faisait du
mal à coucher avec les filles de votre
âge je n'ai jamais eu mon âge mais je
sais josée ouellet
je la connais bah alors je la connais
c'est toujours aime bien ce nom je
travaille dans l' agence de pub bien
quand vous l'avez rencontré comment elle
va fort bien moi dit bonjour bonjour
venue elle est ce que comme tous les
mecs de 64 ans vous prenez du viagra
sans le dire ah non
ah ben non mieux c'est comme tous les
mecs de 104 ans vous pensez que vous
êtes super dans le coup non je suis pas
du tout dans le coup
non non pas du tout non c'est comme tous
les mecs de 64 ans vous mettez à droite
parce que vous avez peur pour vos sous
je n'ai jamais voté
ouais mais tu as des sceaux oui combien
tu as bien les chantres r il travaille
depuis l'âge de 12 ans et c'est comme
tous les mecs de 16 ans 4 ans vous avez
peur de mourir
bien sûr mais j'ai pas attendu ce sont
quatre ans pour accor oui donc ce serait
un truc et qui est vraiment vraiment
chiant mais vous avez rien de grave la
non bajard grave tant mieux mais je l'aï
mal de toute façon non mais oui c'est on
connaît vicieux qui peut vous arriver
une rupture d'anévrisme
donc ça fonctionne bien un point que je
suis à dire avec une action qui prend
des trucs contre la rupture d'anévrisme
a non non non non c'est quoi le truc
contre les ruptures
si l'eau est douce et pas de borne le
bordeaux dit est-ce que comme tous les
mecs de 64 ans il reste plein de trucs à
faire
ah oui il me reste des trucs marrants
affaire voilà
non moi c'est toujours bas je lui en
faire toujours chanteurs sont sanglés
angers me plaît j'arrive en tuellement
de temps en temps des films que j'ai
envie de faire
peut-être un jour terrade peut-être
n'importe quoi je sais pas mais faire
des choses et encore pleins d'envié
ouais ouais
est ce que comme tous les mecs de 64 ans
vous comprenez rien internet
absolument je comprends rien
sûrement oui oui on a plusieurs
d'ailleurs non mais attention comme tu
vas me dire je suis donc très riche
donc j'aime secrétaire celles qui
s'occupent de ça j'ai en plus m'amuser
être puis à noter serein sur un truc qui
rend aveugle et les héros j'ai du mal ay
moi aussi moi j'étais déjà déjà les
nouveaux fronts j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
et un site sur internet aux esquives
bien mais je sais on était super riches
ont gagné 1 200 mille francs
ouais c'est important salaire est ce que
comme tous les mecs de 64 ans vous
entendez mal quand j'entends bien rodé
ses 34 ans oubliez ce conseiller au
début d'interview aujourd'hui tu sais
comme tous les mecs de 64 ans voulait
pas dire vous avez 64 ans gino sur sa
selle on coule
ces jeux